as if thinking Americans can get the
current of hours just by walking outside
wasn't bad enough
well the liberal media are now trying to
spark panic over the president's health
why not get tested yourself after you
interact with Matt Gaetz and Doug
Collins last week no symptoms president
has nothing well that's not good enough
for the experts at CNN when I hear so
many Americans want these tests right I
mean there is a dearth of testing and
that is that the big problem but when
they hear the President of the United
States saying I don't think it's a big
deal
is that the right message all right
you mean the message that the president
is healthy I think that's what Americans
want to hear right and it's what the
real experts are telling him to say I
will say Brooke that actually just
moments ago I got off the phone with an
infectious disease expert and she said
that at her hospital even if you've been
impossibly exposed even if you just got
off a plane from Italy if you don't have
symptoms they don't want to test you
even if you might have been exposed as
perhaps the president was so what he's
saying actually jives with what doctors
are telling me that's the old thing like
when you're in a courtroom
never ask a witness a question you don't
know the answer to okay let's move on
quickly
now remember Trump though they say is
the real science denier but wait CNN
gave this narrative one last shot let me
just get your thoughts should he get
tested I agree with the president if he
has no symptoms there's no reason to
test to test him without symptoms I
don't think people need to be tested and
if the White House doctor says you're
fine you don't have any symptoms you
don't need to be tested I agree with the
White House doctor oh let's go for a
third time joining me now is the doctor
you just heard after mentioned Carlos
Del Rio professor of medicine at the
great Emory University
also with me is dr. mark Segal Fox News
medical correspondent great to see both
of you tonight dr. del Rio what's your
message to those who are pushing this
narrative that it's irresponsible of the
leader of the free world in the midst of
this crisis not to himself rush out to
be tested I mean they are all day long
you've been even hearing this in the
American media well whether you happen
to be the president United States or not
if you don't have symptoms and there's
no indication from a medical physician
that you need to be tested you should
not be tested and we know this from from
from several tests and this is no
different than other tests if you test
people that have a low like hood of
having a disease then the probability
that tests a positive test will be a
false positive increases significantly
so we don't like to test people that
have a have a low likelihood of a
disease and in the case of the president
he had not a direct exposure not a
direct contact
he has no symptoms there's really no
reason to test him yeah and dr. Siegel
we've seen this with this CPAC attendee
who tested positive after the conference
for the corona virus and he shook hands
then they shook hands and then a match
slapped the head of the CPAC came on
this show and I shook his hand and I
hugged his what you know so like I guess
I by this logic I should be tested for
the corona virus and my throat has
nothing to do with a corona versus
laryngitis you forgot that I was in
Nebraska meeting with the nurses and
doctors who took care of actual corona
virus patients right and I didn't get
tested so again it's a multi-level
irresponsibility on the part of all of
us I guess but this just leads a lot of
people to go into deep panic dr. Siegel
and at this point in time I think we've
we've cornered the market on panic we
need calm and preparedness yeah for sure
I mean we we have concern about this
virus but we keep jumping to the
worst-case scenario and envisioning the
worst and that spreads panic that's
what's destabilizing the markets that's
what's getting everybody sequestered in
their homes in this particular case the
president actually showed the right
example I have met
the White House physician he's a very
sober guy he gave his judgments a first
lesson here listen to your doctor doctor
said don't get tested right second
lesson here is he didn't have direct
contact with someone with coronavirus he
had contact with someone who shook the
hand or had a photo op with someone who
had coronavirus so how many times
removed is that if he had gotten tested
Laure he would have been sending a
message to the United States if you're
walking down the street and you hear
that someone in that hospital as
coronavirus get tested we would have a
surge of people that were convinced they
had it so actually he projected calm in
this situation now dr. del Rio tonight
this is a big election night for the
Democrats
okay so Biden sweeps to victory and all
these all these races all these primary
races both candidates have canceled
their big events Biden is addressing
only his I guess as close supporters in
Pennsylvania tonight but Bernie Sanders
is not only not speaking to thousands
like he was paid planned to do he's not
appearing in public apparently out of
concern for the coronavirus it does this
make sense absent some presence in one
of the hot zones or containment zones
such as New Rochelle or maybe in
Washington State well part of the
problem we have laura is that
unfortunately as you know there will say
a mishap in the testing and we are way
behind testing in this country and as we
ramp up testing in the country we were
probably going to find a lot of people
who are infected who we don't know about
and at this point in time until we have
further data we need to assume that
there's a lot more communities that we
are aware of that have community
transmission of the virus and when
there's community transmission one of
the most effective strategies to control
the transmission of a virus like this
one is is what we call social distancing
so it is prudent to establish social
distancing I think it's appropriate that
in many of our communities we try not to
bring a lot of people together until we
have better data once we have better
data I think we can make better
decisions all right well we had go ahead
well I agree with dr. del Rio about his
principles here in the medicine of this
I would not come to the same conclusion
because that's the paranoia again we're
going to assume every single arena we
have
has has coronavirus in it I mean there's
just not we don't have the sense that
there's that much coronavirus here yet
there's definitely more than we know
about he's right about that
but we don't need this fear of going out
outdoors it's a agoraphobia they have a
diagnosis for that let's get the testing
done and then we can decide not not just
avoid everything in the meantime I went
to the knick game last week by the way
there was no one there now the Knicks
are terrible that might be the reason
well the NCAA men's basketball
tournament we all have our pool oh wait
we're not supposed to have a pool here
we have a fake pool here at Fox so we
want the tournament to go on but we
don't want anyone to be endangered
they've already cancelled the merit the
half marathon in New York dr. del Rio
they're cancelling conferences it is it
is doing a huge harm to the travel and
entertainment industry and I think that
in and of itself is sending people into
some panic so they're going to buy water
they're fighting over toilet paper I
mean that can't be good either look you
can get infected by fighting over toilet
paper I guess you take it to its extreme
well in fact in fact I agree with you I
think we don't need to spread panic and
I was talking to somebody today and I
was saying you know the biggest risk you
have may be of going to to a big arena
today or having you know go to a
tournament maybe you know drinking too
much beer and falling and hitting your
head and not for that reason we're not
canceling those tournaments so I would
say again we need better information we
need more data and we need to sit down
and really look at the data carefully
but I couldn't agree with you and with
the doctor any more that we need to do
you know we need people who be prepared
but at the same time we don't need to
spread panic and we got the testing
finally set which is a good thing so
millions of tests will be produced in
the in the coming days and weeks
gentlemen great to have both of you on
extremely reassuring and informative
thanks so much